hey what's up guys I'm Adam Devine I'm
promoting my new movie jexy coming out
October 11th but right now I'm gonna be
deciding which BuzzFeed headline is real
and which one is fake which is the real
BuzzFeed headline because you love dick
okay here's the Disney Prince who'd
fulfill your sexual needs
okay okay I'll see you can we guess how
many people you've slept with based on
your Disney character preferences that's
the real one they're not leading with
dick over at BuzzFeed I believe they
have more class than that let's see
wrong it was the dick one BuzzFeed
emitted Lee I click on that you know
because you love dick
I don't hate dick you know I like mine I
want I don't hate dick okay which is the
real BuzzFeed headline I guess I don't
you guys know what game were playing I
don't know every time 35 foods that
scream
I was the rich friend growing up not me
I was a poor friend covered in that dirt
and the other headline is just 100
pictures of ketchup to send to the
ketchup prison person the ketchup person
in your life why I say prison I think
it's the foods I think it's 35 foods
that scream
I was the rich friend growing up and I'm
right being pbbb beer let's take a sneak
peek at that okay let's see let's see if
I had any of these foods growing up oh
the fancy ice cream how do you what
Vanetta I'm so I was too poor to even
know how to pronounce that ice cream
sun-dried tomatoes are you kidding me
popsicles yeah we had popsicles so yeah
mom and dad you guys did all right
mac and cheese okay well everybody
everybody had mac and cheese I don't
think that was a rich person poor person
thing all Lunchables now some rich choco
taco
you guys member choco tacos dang what
happened to choco tacos
okay we're backing out of this
twenty-one trees that don't have time
for yo bulls if that headline could make
a head gesture that's what it would do
mm-hmm seventeen rotting vegetables that
have better hair than you well I kind of
want to see that but it's for sure the
trees right you guys came in your
cameras so you can't answer but it was
it was the trees so Ryan Gosling looks
exactly like this photo of Monica
Lewinsky's grandpa and I'm shaking
God internet speak man Miley Cyrus is
right knee looks exactly like Seth Rogen
I believe that I believe that yeah and
it was right and it was right well okay
there's Miley there yeah I mean okay
that's that's a little bit of a reach
behind that kind of funny that's old
Seth Rogen too like he's his glow up is
pretty real right now have you seen him
lately
Oh beefcake much I feel like I'm glowing
down I feel like like I'm melting I look
like a candle that has been melting for
a minute
sixty-nine accidental sex from parents
that'll make you plus your pearls
nineteen faces everyone who has had sex
with a penis will recognize these are
naughty well one has 69 in it and that's
fun and the other 19 faces everyone who
has had sex with a penis will recognize
so since I haven't had sex with a penis
I'm just like I don't get this word um
so I'm gonna look at that sex and I
would be wrong because it is the penis
one I kind of look at those nose face
isn't yeah no I don't get it
11 delightful poems found in pornhub
comments 23 sex toy reviews on Amazon
that get better with each sentence
I think it's sex toy reviews and I would
be wrong because it is delightful poems
found in pornhub comments it wax
poetically in those comments when them
butt cheeks be
Ben pickle or Beyonce that's it i'm een
that's a headline pickle obviously and i
would be right i did not see that one
coming
sorry yonce pickles are the new flavor
of the month you 100% need these
pictures of squirrels eating random
things you needed mom I needed you
squirrels or eat a random things I have
to have it mom 26 means to send your
friend in the group chat who never
responds but is always offended yeah I'm
the person that never responds
sometimes group chats get a little
aggressive can we admit that but I do
love some squirrels and I'm right Celine
Dion on a scooter that's it that's the
post who said it drake or her sylvia
plath
well Celine on a scooter that's it
that's the post and I'm right 17 reasons
why avocados are the sexiest food you'll
ever eat
84 things that aren't on an everything
bagel important I mean only 84 that's
where you stop the list for sure they
just got exhausted and we're like
alright
84 is a funny number we'll just stop
there it doesn't it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter they should be reading
the news for sure it's a vaca no it's
not it's 84 things that aren't on an
everything bagel okay guys global
warming is gonna swallow us whole
this couple quit their jobs to travel
and now scrub toilets to get by why are
you outing this couple BuzzFeed couple
just wanted to see the world and go to
Thailand so what if they got a scrub a
few urinals too so they can sip them
drinks poolside these babies will
literally do anything to avoid sitting
in the sand these babies they'll do
anything
I hope the photo is just like a baby
like doing taxes no it's not that's not
even the headline because babies
actually they don't get they'll just sit
and sand their babies they don't know
where they're sitting and he scrubs
toilets
my mom's come to--let's and she didn't
travel anywhere seems like they got a
good gig 19 pictures at every horny
twenty-something can relate to 23 Cosmo
sex positions as
administrator by barbie and ken it's for
sure those sex positions mm-hmm
Barbie and Ken they get wild very
flexible our Hot Cheetos really helping
couples spice up their sex life god I
hope not an investigation in three parts
they they're digging deep this kangaroo
is kind of hot yeah I hope this kangaroo
just looks exactly like Gerard Butler so
yeah and it is it is the kangaroo let's
check out this kangaroo is it the yoked
one I was in Australia recently and I
saw this like yoked ass okay it was like
they're kind of jogs yeah it wasn't this
big this guy's like a professional I go
to the gym all the time and I eat
protein I don't look like this kangaroo
I mean god damn this guy's felt pick out
school outfit and will tell you if
you'll pass or fail in life plan your
dream wedding and we'll reveal what day
you'll die okay you're gonna die the
night of your wedding I'm gonna do it
August 2nd cool
that's oh I'm gonna die Plus we'd really
lifts your spirits last one this is what
Disney Princesses would look like with
septum piercings
yeah I click on that 17 pictures of
Dwayne the rock Johnson but as your
favorite Disney Prince I feel that they
all sort of look like the rock anyways I
want to see them sad some piercings girl
yep and I'm right what's up girl
oh you punk rock on Oh what's up burial
blood Dow how you like me now she
listens to like Neutral Milk Hotel or
some Jasmine what's up girl okay stoner
Mulan sorry sorry I fell in love and
that was it for me Jessie coming out
October 11 see it oh you're so scared
you're so scared I was good at the
computer
[Music]
you